so it's good I'm very I'm in a good
[__] spot and something else happened
in my house this week this has been
going
down this has been going down for about
two years you know but it really came to
life when we moved to this house because
I would keep my
bong under the
bar and I grinder under the bar it was
hidden but the weed is very
pungent yes it is every time people
would come
down you could smell it sometimes my
wife goes you could smell it in the
[__] hallway when you walk in about
three weeks ago I took the bong and I
steamed it cleaned it with the steamer
hot water I boiled it my wife she you
smoking pot in the house the whole house
smells because the bong was [__] deep
in THC and I steamed that [__]
so a couple days I'm talking to my wife
maybe two weeks ago she says to me Joey
you know the cops were at school and
they talked to Mercy about
marijuana wait wait specifically Mercy
or just her class no no the whole class
you know it was like the dead program a
certain cop which I listen you gotta
have that I had that growing up nothing
that that made a
difference be honest
here not that it made a difference I'm
not proud of that but that's the way it
worked out and I told her you know and
then she came back and I said so I heard
they talk to you at uh at school about
drugs today she's like yeah Dad
marijuana and then she just started
rattling off like she absorbed the whole
conversation and she was talking about
how this THC you know like little things
it does this to you that it does this to
you I go
okay about a week
later I come in and I go she goes dad
are we going to go eat something I go
absolutely and I go go change your hair
and get a jacket and I'll wash my hands
and we'll leave well I went outside to
sneak a bong hit and I'm sitting there
with the bong in my [__] hand and she
comes goes Dad I'm ready she saw the
[__] bong guys she saw the fu so I
hid the bong I went in I washed my hands
and I made believe it didn't happen we
had a great time anyway I didn't bring
it up but the whole night I felt weird
and I felt like you
know I gotta come clean with her at some
point I gotta come clean with her about
things I just had to wait for her to
understand you know she's still too
young for a lot of
things uh so she saw the bong and we
[__] footed around and then one night
she comes into the office when I moved
it and my grinder was on the table and
the lid had fallen off it and she looked
at it looked so now I got to say
something to her so I didn't say nothing
to my wife I waited a couple days and
she came downstairs to do something and
I called her over and I go pull up a
chair I gotta tell you a [__] story
oh who shot that who sh and
uh and uh you know I go listen when I
was uh 13 I was raised this particular
way I knew what drugs were and I knew
the evils of
them but one day Mercy I just couldn't
take it and I didn't like alcohol and my
friends were smoking pot and it was it
made me feel terrible I took that
[__] joint I took a hit off it and I
go my world changed M I go I didn't have
anxiety no more but I was very ashamed
of it for two or three years for two or
three years I was very ashamed the
smoking pot I did it with certain people
I I I put cologne on I gargled with
[__] Listerine a little bottle banaka
you know I did the whole thing and then
my mother died I didn't give a [__]
anymore everybody smokes pot you know it
wasn't a big [__] deal so I told her
the truth I said you know I started
smoking blah blah blah and
then I came a couple years ago I did
this and I joined with a company and
that's what laughing at is also she sees
laughing guys and she sees the joint
tubes and she's not
stupid she's not stupid you know she
doesn't know what's in there but she
never really asked now when I was
growing up I lived in that same
predicament I know they were doing
something and then I found out what
people were doing and then when people
would talk about it in front of me I had
to make believe like I didn't know what
they were talking about but in fact I
knew more about drugs than they were
talking about
but I wasn't allowed to say nothing and
that always created like this conflict
with me like this inner [__] conflict
you know I because
you like you had a conflict because you
knew it and like you like you didn't
tell your mom like what was a
conflict the conflict was I saw people
at my mother's bar doing coke I didn't
have the heart to tell other kids it was
1975 I was [__]
12 you know I would see them put the
coke rocks and then I would wake up in
the middle of the night and they'd be in
my living room putting Coke rocks in
their nose with the aluminum fall wide
open I would go into the living room and
talk to them but I would make believe I
didn't look at the aluminum
for at one point they stopped putting it
away and at one point you know it was
just an uncomfortable position but I
knew how to it was it put a it [__]
with me a little bit as a child that you
know what I'm saying like I knew
something that nobody else had a secret
about that here's my living room I'm wai
waking up in the [__] seventh grade
and my mom is cooking and there's
[__] my stepfather's watching TV and
there's three gorillas drinking [__]
snort and Coke in my living room
listening to Cuban music something ain't
right here you know but it was very hard
to come clean with people at that age
and go what are you talking about I just
left [__] three junkies in my living
room right and it's like you're like
your living room now couldn't be more
different like Mercy doesn't have that
at all no so this house is peaceful
there's nobody showing up here stabbed
in the middle of the night and I got to
you know clean his hands with gasoline
because he shot somebody and you know
this my life isn't even close to that
this is a [__] we watch Venom at
night you know the cringe whatever the
[__] it is you know I don't want that in
my house especially for her so I [__]
uh told her I told her what laughing gas
was I explained to her that I made a
living that it was medical
marijuana and it helped people that we
donate to a couple [__] uh PTSD
places you
know and I just didn't want her to live
with that I told her don't say nothing
to your mom and I asked the mom today if
she said something to him she goes no
she hasn't mentioned it to me so we're
straight I feel a lot [__] better now
and next I got to drop another bomb on
her and then I'm going have to drop
another bomb on her because she
understands but she really doesn't
like do you think I'd be talking to you
about this 20 [__] years ago no what
am I doing here but I just want to let
me know that it was a tough decision for
me it was really [__]
tough I pulled it off and I feel better
for doing it I'm not lying to him